hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the fault of June and you're watching
games but news those of you who've
splashed out on the next box one you may
be happy to hear that vine twitter and
HBO Go are coming to the console before
the end of the year the apps are among
45 new entertainment additions that will
be landing on Microsoft consoles which
also includes Showtime anytime Comedy
Central and major league gaming after
the launch of that bunch of the company
are planning on expanding their
collection again by twenty-five percent
which will create a grand total of more
than 225 apps on xbox one and 360
microsoft are also planning to heavily
integrate twitter into xbox one's TV
experience in the US you'll be able to
see sure related tweets come up in real
time and access a training section if
for some reason you want to do that
Microsoft has also launched their June
update with external storage support
today if that's something you want to
take advantage of you can find a full
list of the new xbox apps on site but
you should let me know what app you want
most on your home console if you're a
bit of a speedrun fanatic like me then
you may be interested in seeing this
dark souls 2 bug heavy playthrough where
the speedrunner gets through the entire
game in just over 20 minutes if you're a
speedrun purist who isn't a fan of
exploits and glitches then you won't be
a fan of this one but it's still fairly
impressive to see gamer distortion to
rip through the game world the way he
does often quite literally since eclipse
through walls the run basically boils
down to spending a lot of time skipping
areas using bugs and employing the
in-game binoculars which lets the player
move about all speedy like nerve oculus
I've ever done for anybody else ever in
game or otherwise let me know in that
comments section if you think bug
exploit speedruns are cool or if you
prefer the real deal Xbox loves three
nita day or at least they've said
something nice about their main
competition which is always good to see
specifically Xbox head Phil Spencer has
said that he reckons Sony are going to
have a solid showing at e3 next week
when I'll Stevie thought Sony were
intimidated by Spence's new role heading
up Xbox he replied I don't think Sony
intimidated so needs a great brand and
the strong team competition is good and
they'll have a good e3 he went on to say
that Microsoft's showing at e3 is set to
be one that people will remember and
that the company's confident they're on
a good path Spencer also replied to a
fan who wanted to know what he thought
of industry analyst Michael packed his
comments that Microsoft would likely
spend a lot of their conference
discussing their original TV programming
and not so much games Spencer gave a
pretty vague wait-and-see response and
Microsoft themselves have been pretty
adamant that they'll be focusing on
games this year let me know dad in that
fancy comment box if you think marks
after going to be talking about mostly
games that he threw this year all mostly
other features like integrating TV or
sports it for me today but be sure to
join me again tomorrow where i'll try to
be amusing